when Stefani's emotional night on the  voice I cannot believe you guys are  saving me you know you're saving me I  love you guys the same day reports of  Gavin Rossdale allegedly cheating on  Gwen with the family nanny came out Gwen  had to tape an episode of The Voice and  it was an emotional night on multiple  levels she also had to say goodbye to  three of her contestants I love you guys  so much all I can do in this crazy  moment is just follow my heart and think  of the person that I am gonna be able to  help the most and right now I'm going to  save current moves on congratulations to  green  and Geoffrey I'm braiding sunshine you  guys can go backstage celebrate with  your families we'll see you next week  Le Regina and Victor everybody put your  hands together for these departing  artists whose time on the boys punch to  an end for now